on sait des policiers qui tiennent donc
des propos ouvertement racistes la vidéo
qui a suscité l'indignation sur les
réseaux sociaux le ministre de
l'intérieur a réagi le racisme n'a pas
sa place dans la police républicaine
alors pour reprendre les mots de
christophe castaner y at il un problème
de racisme dans la police le confinement
exacerbe les tensions c'est l'objet de
notre face à face pour en débattre nous
sommes avec nabil boudi avocat à ses
côtés on dirait que par skype également
christophe crépin porte parole du
collectif france police policiers en
colère dont soit messieurs merci d'être
avec nous je repose la question que je
me posais eric coquerel et que soulève
le ministre de l'intérieur christophe
crépin y at il selon vous un problème de
racisme dans la police aujourd'hui en
france je peux pas vous laisser dire
qu'il ya à prendre le racisme dans la
folie la caisse qui on va redonner moi
je ne confirme rien je vous pose la
question alors je vais vous répondre le
clairement madame noël il n'y a pas de
problème de racisme
il y a eu un comportement qui a été
relevé par l'inspection générale qui va
mener une enquête aussi bien
administratives que judiciaire que
monsieur coquerel qui connaît très bien
les procédures se se satisfait de cette
chose
les fonctionnaires qui n'ont rien à
faire chez nous sont systématiquement
des conduits mais dans la police
nationale il n'y a pas de problème de
racisme des chats par son recrutement et
par son mode de fonctionnement
c'est à dire avant de râler c'est
répondre la ville body c'est-à-dire mode
de fonctionnement ça veut dire quoi
bayon ne seront plus les cibles une
police républicaine pour nos services de
toutes les personnes quelles que soient
leurs leur idéologie quelle que soit
leur situation sociale
et quelles que soient leurs ethnies en
fait madame honneur au service de
l'ensemble de la population française et
nabil body est ce que la police est
raciste la réponse est non est ce que la
police était dans grainé par des
comportements racistes
la réponse est oui est-ce que les
suffisamment sanctionné je ne le pense
pas je peux vous donner deux éléments de
réponse en main vie qui sont
intéressants vous savez quand vous êtes
noir vous avez dix fois plus de chances
d'être contrôlé par la police
c'est un comportement raciste pour moi
les contrôles d'identité qui se fonde
sur un critère racial sont des
comportements racistes de la part de la
police
quand vous avez également cinq plus de
54% des policiers qui ont voté en 2017
pour le rassemblement national
ça ne nous dit pas si la police est
raciste ou pas mais ça nous dit que
certains policiers ont fait le choix de
voter pour un parti qui selon moi n'est
pas républicain et vous avez utilisé ce
terme là tout à l'heure le terme de
républicains si ce qu'on attend de la
part des policiers
un comportement républicain ce qui
signifie que l'interdiction formelle de
discrimination aujourd'hui la police
dont a selon moi se poser les bonnes
questions
nous traversons actuellement une crise
sanitaire sans précédent et on attendait
de la part des forces de l'ordre du
discernement de la pédagogie dans les
quartiers dits sensibles et on a vu tout
le contraire c'est-à-dire une
aggravation une explosion des violences
dans les quartiers c'est vrai que ces
images sont extrêmement choquant on
imagine que c'est assez contre productif
si j'ose dire quand on est policier
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti quand
vous avez visionné cette vidéo qui a
fait le buzz sur les réseaux sociaux
moi je suis des fonctions des policiers
bien évidemment cette vidéo ne met pas
en lumière des comportement honorable
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'inspection générale qui a été saisie
fera exactement la part des choses
recadra bien ce qui ça puisse passer si
les fonctionnaires ont dérapé ces
fonctionnaires seront punis à la hauteur
du dérapage qu'ils ont commis mais je ne
peux pas
laissez dire mon contradicteur que toute
la police même ceux qui ont voté pour le
rassemblement national sont racistes
parce que ce n'est pas vrai nous avons
des directives des directives sont
appliquées je peux vous dire que mes
collègues mes collègues qui sont dans
des zones sensibles et sec de faire du
mieux qu'ils peuvent
malgré le manque de moyens et je reviens
on n'a pas de masque on n'a pas de gants
on n'a rien on essaye d'avoir une police
républicaine
c'est vrai que ces comportements ne sont
pas en voyant la vidéo sont pas
honorable pour mes collègues déjà ça
c'est vrai que je dois le reconnaître
mais ce n'est qu'une petite partie
d'individus qui se sont laissés aller
sur des grilles qui ne sont pas très
intelligent de leur part
je pense que ces gens là ils devront
répondre à l'inspection générale du côté
administratif et du côté également au
judiciaire
nabil boudi vous parliez voit la nuit
des temps de contrôle qui sont plus
élevés selon vous et vous dénoncez une
forme de de racisme effectivement depuis
le début du confinement le taux de
verbalisation en seine-saint-denis frôlé
le triple de la moyenne nationale le
département qui totalise 41 1103
contravention pour 242 1259 contrôle
pour être précis pour vous c'est parce
qu'on contrôle plus ou parce que
peut-être il y a moins de respect tout
simplement du confinement on peut aussi
se poser la question sereinement
je suis pas son antre le plus je sais
pas si à plus de violations dessus
confinement mais moi qui habite à paris
je peux vous dire que dans le son plein
en ce moment est d'ailleurs pas plus
tard que tout à l'heure un qui me dit
pour me rendre au cabinet j'ai croisé un
tas demandant leur plu et j'ai vu très
peu contrôlées en commun de
verbalisation le problème de ces
contrôles ce n'est pas les contrats de
vente est de cette attestation qui sont
légitimes pour prévenir de la santé
publique depuis nos concitoyens ce sont
les comportements qui interviennent à la
suite de ces contraintes
vous savez moi je représente une jeune
fille qu'avec
graminées qui a 19 ans elle est sortie
avec une attestation manuscrite de chez
elle elle a fait l'objet d'un console à
la suite de gauche de se contrôler elle
s'est fait tasser par un agent des
services de l'or à bout par bout portant
au niveau de la poitrine vous avez un
individu pas plus tard que le week-end
dernier qui en descendant chez lui pour
prendre l'air s'est fait interpeller et
violenté par une patrouille tout entière
de la police donc ce que je demande
aujourd'hui c'est que le comportement et
l'attitude des policiers qui exercent
dans les centres villes des grandes
agglomérations soit exactement le même
que celui qui a effectué dans les
quartiers populaires et pour ce faire il
va falloir arrêter d'urgence les
contrôles qui sont systématique à
l'égard d'une population désigné et je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure ses contrôles
sont illégaux dans la mesure où ces
contrôles sont discriminatoires
ils sont petits les eaux et je répète il
ya eu tout un tas de communication
aujourd'hui la part de depuis ces
derniers jours depuis l'aggravation de
ces violences policières
la part de certains syndicats de police
je dirais deux choses là dessus
heureusement dieu merci que ces
syndicats ne sont pas représentatifs de
la police française aujourd'hui qui fait
un travail remarquable et mon propos a
est un peu tronqué par nouveaux
indicateurs je n'ai pas dit que tous les
policiers des racistes j'ai seulement
précisé que compte tenu de leurs
fonctions la police doit d'être
irréprochable
c'est celle-ci qui est censé apporter la
sécurité aux français si aujourd'hui
vous avez des français qui se sentent
menacés qui ont peur d'être contrôlé par
la police
c'est qu'il ya un problème qui est
structurelle et donc on n'a pas arrêté
ce problème de fond la crainte sera
toujours présente et les accusations de
racisme père du roi envers la police
qu'est ce que vous répondez un habile
boudy je pense que monsieur vous dites à
un excédent avec hakim et un peu d'huile
sur le feu là où il ya tout et pas lieu
de remettre
moi je vous dis que en effet dans le 93
il y à beaucoup plus de gens qui ne
respectent pas le gros le confinement
que dans paris c'est un service
bible notre syndicat nous avions demandé
que l'argent des verbalisations soit
reversée pour refaire une réforme
complète du système hospitalier
c'est une idée parce que c'est vrai que
ça va faire quand même beaucoup d'argent
à paris je vous assure monsieur que le
préfet de police
allez mes instructions pour contrôler
toutes les contrevenants qui soit ils
devoir et quelle que soit leur
nationalité je vous assure que c'est
vrai je vais pas débattre avec vous
parce que je pense que vous êtes dans
l'idée de dire que la police n'est pas
spécialement toujours exemptes de
reproches et je vous assure qu'on essaye
de faire tout ce que nous pouvons pour
ne faire aucune preuve de racisme à
l'égard de personnes de suivre et à
paris rencontre autant que dans 93 ou
que dans le 94 ou que dans le 92
nabil boudi quand un policier on entend
des relations les radios aujourd'hui en
france à la suite de cette affaire
des policiers des témoignages simple
d'hommes qui disait voilà c'est très
difficile parfois de travailler dans ces
quartiers il ya des bandes de jeunes
entre guillemets voilà je cite un
policier que j'écoutais chez nos
confrères de france info au miroir et
des bandes de cinq ans qu'il nous dise
où on ne respectera pas le confinement
de toute façon ne payera pas demande est
ce que c'est un fait que vous contestez
et si vous ne le contesté parce que vous
n'estimez pas que c'est parfois
peut-être difficile pour un policier de
travailler dans ces conditions également
je conteste cette allégation selon
laquelle dans certains quartiers le
confinement sur les moins bien respectés
d'ailleurs c'est absolument faux
rappelez-vous que personne et la mémoire
courte
au début du confinement sur les quais de
seine au trocadéro
les attroupements rappeler que dans le
grand est aussi dans certains lieux de
culte ou la pire était maintenue malgré
le confinement rappelez vous également
dimanche jour ensoleillé a parlé ce qui
s'est produit dans le signal en ce sens
je vais quasiment tous les jours dans le
16e arrondissement et j'ai à ce jour
aujourd'hui l'impression que le
confinement n'a jamais eu lieu dans
certains avançant paris pourquoi ça
dégénère
pourquoi les pas de violences policières
pourtant les personnes ne se confine pas
ne respecte pas l'état d'urgence à lider
tout simplement parce que la police a
agi avec retenue et si cette retenue qui
doit prévaloir sur tous les contrôles
d'identité
ce camp distinction et quand ces
contrôles d'identité seront réalisés de
la même manière sur tout le territoire
français
on pourra considérer que tous les
policiers sont républicains ce n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui et je pense que la
police a beaucoup à y gagner aujourd'hui
à se poser les bonnes questions et
notamment période de crise tous les
individus doivent être aidés à la même
enseigne
je ne fais pas le procès de la police la
police d'un travail remarquable mais il
ya certains syndicats il ya certes un
policier aujourd'hui qui nous dit ceux
qui agissent avec très peu de décence et
qui que j'ai taxis noirs de comté
pyromane resterait pas le mot de la fin
ne me suis pas du tout en accord avec
les propos que viennent de tenir mon
contradicteur donné en moi et il faut
que les français comprennent bien que la
police est à l'heure et la peau à les
protéger et on continuera à avoir une
police républicaine si quelquefois il ya
des dérapages et sow sévèrement mais
très sévèrement punis et très souvent
les collègues qui ont commis ce genre de
dérapages ils sont exclus profession et
ils ont des sanctions judiciaires qui
sont très lourdes même plus l'autre que
le commun des mortels voilà ce que je
viens c'est qu'a rappelé on est là pour
protéger les citoyens quelle que soit
leur rythme en quelle que soit l'heure
de leur classe sociale et on lui
protégera merci beaucoup à tous les deux
nabil boudi christophe crépin d'avoir
été avec nous pour débattre